in germany internet technology
we were always very left behind and had
problems and have been
there for years there for that i'm
marco herrmann live here in mose
my whole life six years old
myself and am currently the
mayor of mose
[music]
politicians and  processing fixed
internet to people like and places like
mose from modern and hate i am
convinced that the future of
rural areas
depends to a large extent on the technical
possibilities being the same there
first of all we want to expand the infrastructure
so that everyone has access
to digital possibilities
[music]
the internet control has the internet
stream of data germany is in germany
international regions mike moses
homestake saxony-anhalt open
the vostro in the village the internet
coupler from cables who guides the back to the
early ninety nine is engist
couple of data connector fiber  optic
cables
yes and I think so  e also that you also
why is a mirror image for the whole of
germany two kilometers away
there is internet here there is no
politics market suspects the rollout of
[music]
germanys internet
we had now also has the
liberalization of
internet supply at night will become the
general so far  in municipal and
state hands we were all
liberalized my name is situation
and i am responsible is a
company that deals with the construction of
data and electrons last
and has been owned for 50 years
to 9 no dies wave of gravity session also
included germany state
telekom and deutsche telekom
which operator countries from connections
companies will comes or customer
marketing
mansion.com helmut kohl
[music]
with merkel's connections es 50 megabit
we have exactly the same
burrows on the same strand of the rhine, yes
, he does  Of course, there are also some
official constraints and you can
actually  make and who owns the
country and everything is difficult and there you are of
course the german bureaucracy that
is not beneficial the trio of
german internet access 1 precaution
internet
[music]
and broadband expansion is so important
energy and so important we
say
in the  santa corona it was on so my
name is because shorten i am 37
years old in moser and work as a
telephone consultant
our employer tried to
outsource our say now to keep the
distances also made all the
technology available for
it we tried it  doesn't
work
that means i was in the
moment to go back to the office
sometimes you're really scared you
didn't have to at first how do you stick
to whom do you
stick to your colleagues especially when you come
home
maybe you have each other
don't think of workers, you stick it to the family
here,
it just showed again how
important it is  it is one
that you have to have normal line in the
future we will definitely create the internet for
it, especially in the
rural regions
what if i then the real
disadvantaged people will be second class
germany has said and include the right
to the internet connection
[music]
here in not least the future is coming
many companies our commitment has
led to the fact that we now at least have
mose input fiber optics and can
then use somewhat faster internet via the old copper lines
we can play something together
an endgame so everything
is not possible
with the line we say so
we are the ones to 1 2 100 measuring
stations caps fiber optic connections the way to
the
home well the experience now with the
regional telecommunications company
is now  actually shows
the drop statements now not
definitely prove yourself if
that really happened i'm still
a bit skeptical
the story of moses pen by eflow
internet relay chat on the champs
angela merkels coming to close
in september selections german speaking
ob germany's internet
[music]